hi everyone it's Jerry I have a very
nice game to share with you from 2004
between Alexander morosevic on the white
end and Victor bolagon the Finish to
this one is definitely one of the more
memorable ones you'll find to a game
very sharp flashy finish to this one to
be sure
and you really wouldn't expect it given
the opening Carroll Khan defense
typically this opening leads to slower
more positional games
in the early stage with this one it does
develop a bit on the slow side but once
opposite sides castles hits
uh
it's game on there's a race who could
get it one another's King first things
will quickly sharpen from there
now the variation white chooses in this
one F3 the fantasy
what is one of the ideas behind this
fantasy variation well
it's looking to combat a main idea by
black in the Carroll Khan defense or the
main idea by black in the Carol con
which is to say get this guy doing
something
get it outside of the pawn chain to F5
or G4 and only then play E6
with the fantasy white is saying
you can't do that I got these squares
still covered and if you want to
activate your light Square Bishop you're
going to have to work a little harder
you're gonna have to maybe make some
concession
Black's reply to this is simply E6 he
says fine
I'm not going to try and get out along
this diagonal I'll look to develop it
elsewhere and your knight can't go to
its favorite Square
okay
if black wants to activate the light
Square Bishop he can and this here is
considered the main line to initiate the
capture
on e4 and then immediately challenge
this duo with next placing an emphasis
on developing the queen side miners
this is how we could see the light
Square Bishop find a productive role
it's pinning the Knight
after Bishop C4 very important moment
now for Black Knight D7
with Bishop C4 white is threatening a
tactic to capture on F7
followed up with Knight takes E5 check
and then Queen takes Bishop
so this main line goes much deeper of
course but I wanted to at least give you
a little taste of what this main line
looks like
in this game it is simply E6
and we get some more development in
Knights out Bishops out
Queen D3 I think a couple things when I
see Queen D31 whites just a moment away
now from Queen side castles and two
there's still a delay with the King
Knight White's still giving black the
option to initiate this capture this
would be a bad decision by black
because now this Knight gets to make use
of
its favorite Square
okay from here black goes with B6 this
Black's way to activate the light Square
Bishop all the more appealing with the
queen on a queen on D3
okay from here the knights are now
connected
Bishop A6 hits
Queen E3 kingside castles for black met
with Queen side castles
okay from here play sharpens with C5
A3 and now an interesting sequence here
we're going to have a minor piece in
bounce
Bishop takes Knight
and another Bishop takes Knight followed
up with
can you guess the next move very
instructive moment right here how would
you reply as black
feel free to pause the video
okay black goes with the consistent
follow-up
C4
now on one hand
you may think to yourself wait a second
we have opposite sides castles isn't the
idea to open lines towards the enemy
King
yes but I believe in this case making
a capture like this is benefiting white
more than black for two reasons one this
Rook has helped
on the D file and two more Pawn
exchanges generally will favor the side
with the bishop pair more Pawn exchanges
more open diagonals for the Bishops
with C4
black wants to play within a closed
environment this generally speaking is
where the knights will thrive
closed positions
okay
black has an idea on a with a pawn break
this guy right here
kind of sticks out like a sore thumb
B5 A5 and B4
is a plan for black to be sure
okay where do we go from here we have to
start pushing some pawns towards the
enemy King
was the idea at some point create some
tension with one of these guys right
around the corner from that tension is a
capture and there you go you'll have a
file that is opened or half open for
the Rooks to get at the king
all right B5
Queen E1 Knight B to C6
H5 Queen D7 G5 and now an instructive
moment here f
6 this is considered a best move
this move takes into account
a couple Pawn advances by white
the reply in this game is Bishop F1
if white continues in this position with
h with H6 there's a couple ways black
can reply to this one is just going one
step
but another is even two
this F6 move assists in G5 with tempo
with the idea to next fight over this F4
Pawn break
that's one approach
for black
in reply to H6 what about G5 well in
reply to G5 this is where there's
tension and this is where black can yet
again say no I don't want a file to open
up the G file in this case I'm going to
go here and keep things still closed
and now looking at it further
if white in this position continues with
G6 that's met with H6 if white goes with
H6 Black's going with G6 in both cases
the G and H files remain closed and this
will buy black time to pursue an attack
on the queen side
okay
what is White's idea with
underdeveloping the bishop well I noted
with F6 the positives the different ways
you can be reacting to the pawn play
what's a negative well E6 is a whole
because of this last move the bishop
wants to eye that up he's headed for H3
White's looking to coordinate on this
point
all right from here we have Rook a to d8
this isn't considered best
what's considered best is to still make
use
of this post on A8 with the Rook
it wants to go with A5
and next B4 see how white reacts to that
and only later make a decision with the
Rook
this is another instructive moment right
here if A5 is played in King B1 and then
B4 white would be taking
this approach right here he would be
going with A4 making sure the B file
does not open up
keeping things closed
okay
in this game though Rook a to d8 Black
does have an idea here to have a timely
capture in the center followed up with
Knight takes D4
there's soon going to be three attackers
on that point
Bishop H3
Pawn takes Pawn how to recapture
on e4
how would you recapture here feel free
to pause the video
okay the best way to recapture is with
the pawn
were any of you tempted by this idea my
Queen's on the back rank let's recapture
and develop
don't do that because
this guy right here
currently in this position right here
currently is zero let's call it and this
would be one of these Zero to Hero type
moves you'd be giving black
it no longer you're the pawn no longer
controls D5 and this Knight is now all
of a sudden not just a best piece for
black but a best piece in the game
okay white needs to control in other
words this second ranked Knight
okay
in comes Knight takes D4
y continues this bishop now has a clear
view of E6 black does not want the G
file to open up there is tension here
F5 very instructive game
with Pawn play here
from here King B1
there's no taking advantage of this
pinned Knight in this position for
instance C3 could be met with Knight B3
check and then the queen could get out
of danger
with King B1 though now this is right
around the corner
black sniffs that out gets off of the D
file
from here H6
Pawn takes Pawn
Queen C3 now
this is not considered the best move we
have a case of back to back mistakes or
blunders here one by white one by black
what is considered best in this position
is the following move and this is really
really interesting I'll throw it to you
as a pop quiz Can you spot what is the
best move here feel free to pause the
video
okay this here is the best move
Bishop E5
now in order to play that move you have
to foresee a queen sacrifice
now Bishop E5 for instance Knight C3
what are you doing here
seems like you're running into
a fork and black is winning black is not
winning
because
white could play Queen takes E4
What's Happening Here well after Queen
takes queen look at these monster
Bishops
check King here
how's that for me
okay so this is really an overwhelming
attack here white has a lot of pieces
these two Bishops
this potential opening up of the H file
upon
could take away all the squares from the
King you don't need a queen in this
position as white
no Bishop E5 in this game Queen C3 this
Knight can't go over wherever he wants
we have a mate possibly on G7
in this game E3 is played this is a
blunder from this point on white is
winning
what is considered best withdrawing this
Knight
blunting this diagonal shielding
uh the bishop it's no longer eyeing E6
directly and at the same time welcoming
more exchanges black is the side who is
under pressure black is the side who's
on the defensive
what's a way to ease this defensive task
welcome exchanges we have the Rooks now
in tension this is considered best also
worth noting the Knight is defending
against the mate threat on G7
alright in this game
black advances the past pun
Rook takes Knight follows
this is giving up the rook in the corner
Queen takes Rook
white has this calculated after King A2
now what do you do
black continues in the best way Queen
takes Bishop but this is still
completely winning for white because
after Rook takes Rook you don't have
time to take back
Queen takes G7 would be mate
in this game black captures on H6
if the Knight goes to F5 in this
position
this is how white could reply
Queen E5
and after Rook takes Rook Queen takes
Pawn not only check but pinning the
Knight
doesn't matter where the King goes next
up there's Pawn takes Pawn
the Knight cannot take because the queen
would fall
at the end of all this eventually
this Rook Falls
and we get to a position like this where
the bishop gets to go here with check
if you're not if you're not capturing
the bishop in this position
you're going to get mated so you're
gonna end up losing the queen
King G7 in this position we would have
mate on f8
in short
if Knight F5 Queen E5 is a excellent way
to follow up
in this game it is simply G takes H6
G takes H6 we have a mate thread on G7
black defends that we're one move away
from black resigning
Can you spot
the final move of this game feel free to
pause the video
all right here we go as mentioned a very
flashy
sharp memorable finish to this one
Queen h8
black resigns
how valuable is this Pawn pretty
valuable
uh it's not a one point pawn it feels
more like it's a major piece it's
setting up a beautiful mating net
what are Black's options if the game
continued from here
if the King goes to F7 it's a main two
with Queen takes H7 check
Queen blocks you simply take the queen
if the king steps up rook takes Rook is
me
and the other way is to take the queen
this is going to lead to mate in a very
pretty way
Rook takes Rook two ways to block
if you block with the queen this is mate
straight away
and if you block with the Knight we
would have Bishop here again and I don't
know
what would be your way to deliver mate
in this position
for me I'm going with the pawn
how's that for a pretty finish
okay anyhow after this final move Queen
h8
black resigns in this one
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it it
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye